everyone please bear with us for just a
moment while I start the live stream
audience for our LinkedIn viewers
take me just a moment
and there we go so welcome to everyone
on our LinkedIn live stream and our
YouTube live stream and of course
everyone watching here on the WebEx
application
and I'm here with Matt Bailey
I'm at
and here is our topic today digital
marketing Trends impacting your career
in 2023
for those of you on WebEx please put
your questions for Matt into the Q a
panel
and uh and
also send messages through the uh all
panelists chat but we'll take questions
out of the Q a mainly and then you are
watching on the live stream put your
questions into your screening
applications chat or comment box
to be able to get those passed on to us
and we'll also be doing a couple of
polls during this process
find out more about you in the audience
so I'm going to ask a first poll
question before we
get into the presentation and this one
two parts first how much experience do
you have we like to get that kind of
feeling of who's in the audience
this is not necessarily experience in
digital marketing but just general
experience in the workforce
and then
we also have a checking question to see
how you're doing
we've been asking this throughout the
pandemic is
surges come and go lock Downs open and
shut and people work from home and go
back to the office
all the different stresses so here we go
and
this is an interesting result because
it's the flattest distribution I think
I've seen where of people of uh
experience levels so we have a just a
spectrum and um good to see that most
people are doing pretty well or
okay and we hope that what Matt has to
share with you third are from college
and university which is that's probably
I think one of the largest
representations of College University
students I think we've had Stuart oh
that is great yeah that's probably true
I mean um
we have other types of webinars that
have more heavy representation of of
students and pressures but uh
in your
webinars we've generally seen people who
are into their careers and yeah that
type of thing but this will because it's
a career webinar uh today we're talking
to people who are interested in getting
started in the field or maybe pivoting
into the field uh as well as those who
are already digital marketers who want
to
see what's ahead for the year so
um I'll let you talk a little bit about
yourself and then I'll stop fearing this
screen and let you go ahead and share
yours
all right first go ahead and introduce
yourself all right well thank you Stuart
uh my name is Matt Bailey I've been in
digital marketing now for going on 25
years uh started building websites in
the mid to late 90s and taught myself
how to do analytics because I need to
know is this worth doing and how much
money am I making from it uh so from
there learn search engine optimization
paid search of course social media as it
was still in its infancy in the 90s
Believe It or Not social media did not
start with Facebook in 2012 it actually
was around before the modern internet uh
so we've seen all these changes and um
so yeah I I do a lot of training and
teaching in the industry I've worked
both brand side and agency side but now
focus on training which takes me all
over the world uh just last week I did
webinars for people in Romania but then
also I just got back home from Dubai uh
so it's been an exciting few months in
the training world
that that's that's pretty exciting did
you get a chance to hop over to cut
cutter for the uh roll trap
no I watched it at some of the viewing
places there but they were running 60
flights a day uh from Dubai to Qatar to
uh to see the world cup so it was
absolutely amazing that's pretty amazing
okay well I'm going to turn it over to
you and uh you have the screen sharing
control so all right over to you I will
bring that up thank you Stuart and thank
you again simply learn for allowing me
to come in and present to you uh really
looking forward to it and I this is
going to be a little different of a
presentation
because we're going to talk about your
career we're going to talk about digital
marketing Trends and your career so it's
going to be a little bit different
because as you have questions put them
in the Q a all right I can see some of
the Q a popping up here
um I try to keep an eye on it while I'm
talking uh but if Stewart if any good
questions come up feel free to jump in
and let me know what they are especially
if they are focused on the content that
is on the screen at that time
all right great here's what I'm doing I
am going to approach this as if I were
going to invest in the stock market or
if I were going to invest my career into
anything right now where would I invest
and so I'm gonna have a little bit of an
investment banking or stock market theme
here because there is so much happening
in the digital marketing or the digital
career
area that really we've got to look at it
as if we were investing money or
ultimately we're investing time and
we're investing our careers so I'm going
to go at it from that aspect and the
first thing and this might not be a
surprise to anybody if if it comes to my
career and let's say I have stock to
sell I am selling everything I've got in
Twitter and I'm selling what I have in
Facebook now a couple of reasons for
this and you know what's going on with
Twitter and you may be on the side that
said elon's going to solve it he's going
to turn it around you may be on the side
that elon's destroying it he he doesn't
know what he's doing either way
advertisers are leaving people are
leaving Elon might be able to send a
rocket into space he might be able to
create a electric car but when it comes
to Twitter he has to make millions of
people happy
in order to use his product it's not
like solving a technical problem this is
marketing this is creating a service
that people want to use and the moves
that he's made some of the things that
are happening if I have Twitter stock
I'm selling it on the other side of the
world
Facebook
who would have thought two years ago
that Facebook would have lost more than
half of its value in the stock market
who would have thought that this would
have been possible Facebook was on top
of the world in terms of how many users
in terms of gaining users around the
world and it's interesting because in
the U.S Facebook's been flat but around
the world it's still gaining but yet
when Mark Zuckerberg makes the decision
to spend billions of dollars in the
metaverse with very little to show
investors people looking at Facebook are
pulling out and they're not they don't
have the patience uh to see what's
happening and when Facebook had to
eliminate jobs when they had to draw
down because they're putting so much
money into metaverse and really what
what Zuckerberg is presenting really
isn't that impressive and so no one is
sold on what's happening in these two
platforms they are really it's like I
said it's amazing what a year can do
because these two platforms a year two
years ago were on top and now
people are are really eyeing them very
suspiciously
all right I'm also going to sell
programmatic advertising
because programmatic advertising over
the it's always had a problem with fraud
it's always had a problem with bot
traffic and by bot traffic I mean
bot traffic where's my pen it's it's
disappearing here
there we go bot traffic robots Okay more
Bots are seeing programmatic ads than
humans uh and and we're seeing more and
more headlines come up that are showing
the problems with programmatic because
advertisers are spending a lot of money
and right now they can't track we're
almost a third of the money goes
everyone takes a piece of it and
Publishers ultimately get less than 50
cents on the dollar for every
programmatic dollar spent but even then
advertisers if you buy cheap traffic
chances are it's not human look at this
report here of programmatic campaigns
where you can see we have Impressions uh
you know for for one day here running in
the in the around the 40 000 impressions
for each of these campaigns however less
than 200 actual humans out of those
thousands tens of thousands of
impressions
but yet advertisers that are going
direct to Publishers that are creating a
one-on-one and avoiding the programmatic
market the programmatic auction and
Marketplace they are the ones that are
reaching the humans they're not reaching
Bots and so if I'm looking at my career
I'm also looking at where I'm going in
my marketing and what I'm going to do to
be more effective I am pulling
everything out of programmatic
advertising especially if I have
agencies that say they have fraud
detection it's not in the agency's best
interest to do fraud detection their job
is to deliver you views regardless of
whether or you know and the best way to
see if it's Bots or humans is analytics
it's not fraud detection software so
these are that's one area I'm starting
to sell and I'm going to look at other
where other places to put my money now
where I'm gonna hold right now I'm
holding on the metaverse all right as I
said Facebook is putting billions of
dollars into it there have been concerts
in the metaverse there have been product
announcements there have been all kinds
of things happening in the metaverse
but the problem is with all these
billions of dollars being spent on the
metaverse the amount of people in the
metaverse attending these events is
actually very small it's tiny compared
to what's happening on the other
platforms you wouldn't think by the
amount of news coverage that the
metaverse only has maybe less than a
million people in it at a time and
that's not a large number compared to
the the millions the billions of people
that are on other platforms it's
actually very very small and also
what does it take to get into the
metaverse well it takes a high-speed
connection it takes a very powerful
computer it takes goggles it takes a
headset which costs quite a bit of money
and so the barrier to entry of the
metaverse is very high when you compare
it to Simply the ability to download an
app on my phone and have immediate
access
so the metaverse with that barrier it's
an economic barrier uh it is you know a
barrier to so many people and also
there's a level of trust that goes on
there because if you're completely
connected that means all your data is
being collected and if Facebook's
involved you know your data is being
collected so I'm holding on the
metaverse I'm watching to see what's
being done now I see that there are
great applications being designed
specifically in the B2B the medical
world
but they're typically more in a Walled
Garden they're typically in their own
area it's not for public it's for
private it's for businesses to develop
something that they can share and work
with with their Specialists from all
over the world
but what's building the metaverse is
Brands and Brands rarely build anything
first
people that build something and then the
brands come along when they see the
people are there right now your primary
Builders are brands
Tick Tock now Tick Tock is still growing
till tick [ __ ] is still building
relationships building coverage however
I'm holding on it because more and more
countries around the world are
evaluating Tick Tock I mean India
already blocked it uh it's not available
there they've got their own products in
the U.S they're reviewing it and
government employees are not allowed to
have tick tock on their government
phones and so we're starting to see
around the world a lot of questions
being asked about who owns the data how
much access uh is the data have in China
and what's going on so not just the us
but the EU and many other countries are
re-evaluating how to deal with Tick Tock
and how much it it is you know it's
beneficial and should it be regulated or
Limited
so there's a lot going on with Tick Tock
uh if you saw some of the information
that came out recently that China has
its own version of tick tock and then
they have the version that they
Unleashed on the world
see the Chinese version of tick tock if
you're under 15 years old you are
limited to 30 minutes
that's it
China limits and it not only does that
it curates the content that miners will
see on the app you see if you're under
15 in China and you go to tick tock you
see science experiments science
experiments that you can do at home you
get
uh educational content you get content
about nationalism and so you get curated
content and then after 30 minutes you're
done
the what they call the Opium version The
Addictive version of tick tock that's
what China sent to the rest of the world
and that's why so many countries so many
governments are reevaluating where
they're going with Tick Tock so I'm
gonna watch it I may use it for
advertising but it's one of those areas
where I'm going to just be very wary of
where things go there now where am I
going to buy I'm gonna buy on YouTube
I'm buying in on LinkedIn and I am
buying in on Instagram
has one of the fastest now again in the
US Instagram has gone flat around the
world Instagram is growing more and more
people using Instagram yes I know it's
tied to Facebook that's what makes
things very difficult how are you going
to use your area so it's just really
interesting because even among different
countries
um as I had mentioned I I spent some
time in the Middle East and in Egypt
Snapchat is number one uh in Saudi
Arabia I think
um I'm trying to think what it is I
think Tick Tock or one of them in the
UAE Instagram is one of the most used
it's just really interesting how even in
different countries you see this change
and shift but in every country in every
country Middle East uh Asia Africa us
the number one social media is always
YouTube and it's interesting because
people don't always think of it as
social media
YouTube by far is viewed more than
almost any other website in fact if you
look at the top search engines all right
number one search engine around the
world except in different regions China
Russia and some other countries have
their own but Google Google is and not
surprised to anyone it's the number one
search engine
the number two search engine and
actually two and three kind of flip-flop
the number two search engine is Google
images
that's the number two search engine in
the world the number three search engine
is YouTube
Google owns the top three search engines
being used around the world
um LinkedIn from a B2B standpoint
LinkedIn has always been at the top and
Linkedin is continually adding more
versatility more methods of building
audiences of engaging with people
LinkedIn is is really in a high growth
trajectory and it's very unique among
the B2B world it's where you go if you
have an audience for that so those three
social networks I am buying because they
are growing and they're constantly
attracting new users
now also as a strategy I'm buying
content marketing
it's going to increase uh just this uh
recent survey just a few months ago
companies are going to increase their
budgets in content marketing because
content marketing what I love about it
is that it utilizes so many other
disciplines if you're doing content
marketing you are naturally doing SEO
with your content you're also naturally
doing social in order to get more
Distribution on there you're also using
paid you're either using paid search or
paid social to extend what you're doing
you're building landing pages you're
you're developing all that and you're
also doing a heavy dose of Analytics
to figure out what's working why it's
working and how I can get more out of
this so content marketing as a strategy
naturally involves all these digital
disciplines and of course when you're
doing everything you're going to see
great results and so we could see here
uh at least half of companies are going
to be increasing their budgets uh
between one and nine percent in the next
year so this is a growth Opportunity by
the Way digital marketing is estimated
to be at at a a
320 billion dollar industry all right
320
billion all right that is the digital
marketing industry
it is estimated to double in the next
five years to over
640 billion
that is crazy do you realize how crazy
that is that digital marketing is poised
to double over the next five years that
means if you have your digital marketing
credentials and experience now within
the next year
in five years look at how many managers
will be needed if the industry doubles
that means you could be managing in five
years that means you could be considered
senior in five years that is what's
happening in the industry right now so
getting a hold on these skills and
developing them and growing and building
your experience is going to pay off as
this industry grows
all right I have a one one question
related to content marketing that came
in from Dinesh and he asks
do you think that chat GPT and other AI
tools are going to replace content
writers and website Developers
I'm so happy you asked that question
janash great great question all right
I'm going to go back and slide in here
chat DBT thank you for bringing that up
here so I've used it I have talked to
other people to use it and yesterday I
interviewed an AI uh specialist about
this
chat GPT
from a Content standpoint
I did some work in it to see what it
would do and what it created all right
what it gave back to me was probably I
would describe at the level of an intern
I asked it to look at certain content in
a in a certain area I read through it
and it was if I asked a very
inexperienced person who had a basic
knowledge of the industry put it
together now the AI specialist I talked
to he had a look at four articles and to
create a summary and his assessment was
the same it was it was basically intern
level work and that's where we're at
right now it's from a Content production
standpoint you're not going to get
Advanced content also the problem with
chat chat GPT is it is creating
citations that don't exist
uh it very easily will state things as
fact that aren't
uh so we've got a lot of gaps it's got a
long way to go here's the thing now
where I found it valuable is it helped
me look at a subject from the outside
see sometimes we can be so close to
something that we forget and so as far
as coming up I think GPT could be good
for keyword research I think it could be
good for coming up with topics I think
it could be good for helping you see
areas of the industry that you might
miss but as far as writing something
that I would immediately press post on
absolutely not absolutely not we've got
a long way to go from there
um as it was explained to me what chat
GPT is doing is it's word prediction
it's all it's doing is taking a keyword
or concept and predicting what the next
word would be that's all it's doing
so there's no
thought there's no soul there's no
experience behind it and I hope that
answers your question Dinesh but yeah
thanks for bringing that up
all right I'm gonna move on here too and
and this is it so the reason why I was
in Dubai is I went to the 1 billion
follower Summit uh two days over a
hundred speakers and those 100 speakers
added up together had over 1 billion
followers all right and so it was
fantastic this event had over 16
000 applications from people to attend
they they ended up they limited it to
uh 3 500 attendees from over 100
countries it was incredible it was
amazing and so here's a few things that
I saw what was going on number one no
one called themselves an influencer all
right and that's because the industry
perception no one wants to work with an
influencer
people want to work with a content
creator all right so we're shifting some
labels here we're shifting some of these
things because I mean when I when you
hear the word influencer what's a first
thing that comes in your mind you're
thinking of typically it's that fake
lifestyle
content uh we're not a lot of
authenticity uh and they're always
looking for the Big Brand deals
that is a negative perception about
influencers in and out of the industry
but what where the growth is where
people are seeing results is as a
content creator
the even brands are realizing this is is
it's better to focus on micro
influencers the the content creators
that have a relationship with their
audience that are creating community
that have personal connections
a a good influence on their audience
meaning a strong tie and connection and
they're creating education and
entertainment
so there's a big difference right now
between an influencer and a content
creator the label is changing and people
are defining who I am and why I'm here
and creating more authentic
relationships with their audiences
so that's one of the things that uh I I
came out of that but I've been seeing it
more and more in the industry
now here's also what I'm buying I am
buying the EU all right if you've been
watching the news over the past few
weeks the EU is taking
these large tech companies to task they
are they are determining how Google
Facebook will grow in the EU and how
they will do business
the the EU over the past few weeks has
dropped decisions on Google and Facebook
that they must change if they are going
to operate in the EU they need to change
their data privacy how they collect data
how they process data and how they
target people the EU has gone after them
for Anti-Trust monopolistic practices
and limited some of the things that they
can do they need more user protection in
terms of advertising as well as illegal
content the EU is leading the way among
the rest of the world on fighting these
large tech companies like Google and
Facebook or meta all right those two in
particular Google and meta EU is
dictating how they will do business and
it's interesting because these are a lot
of things that especially in the US
government they haven't done main reason
is because the big tech companies they
Lobby the US government for favorable
laws and regulations
they don't do it in the EU and the EU
actually is more concerned about privacy
they're more concerned about Anti-Trust
and monopolistic practices and so we're
seeing a major shift when the world is
telling Google and Facebook you can come
here but here's how you're going to do
business so I'm watching the EU and how
they handle the tech companies because
this is going to determine how things
evolve over the next few years
also I'm buying anything that has to do
with privacy anything with privacy uh it
when the president uh and this is the
thing Google has been handed down a lot
of decisions about privacy and still
when Google talks about privacy I do
laugh uh and it was interesting that
Google did a survey of Europeans 7 000
Europeans and they said that when Brands
respect privacy the ads perform better
go figure and also if you have a bad
privacy experience with a brand 43
percent of Europeans said they will
switch to another brand
and includes a search engine
so when Google realizes that they need
to change practices that they need to
refocus and develop more privacy
controls and allow people to manage
their own privacy and data people
respond to that people like that we'll
see what Google does about that
I am also buying economies when you look
around the world and see where things
are growing where uh where what's
happening U.S news and World Report just
issued a report about the fastest
growing economies in the world right now
the fastest growing economies are in
the UAE Egypt Qatar and Saudi Arabia
those are the world's fastest growing
economies and they are making waves uh
you know as Stuart and I talked a little
bit about the World Cup and Qatar they
have gotten worldwide attention uh for
this and they are making moves to be
World players along with the other
countries however other countries in
recession what's going on in Russia
right now uh with the war in Ukraine the
Russian economy is taking massive hits
as well as digital Talent is leaving
most of the digital talent in Russia has
all if they haven't left already they're
leaving because the lack of Freedom the
the the the fear of what's Happening uh
and so so many tech companies have moved
out of Russia into other countries and
Russia has lost its its future in terms
of knowledge capital and their economy
is going to be taking a major hit over
the next could be the next decade or two
but also in Europe we're seeing some
other economies in recession uh Germany
Italy uh I've got Germany down there
twice uh Germany and Italy uh they are
seeing some recessions as well
um and so watching the world economies
where is innovation taking place where
are new and this is where it was
measured startups uh where are the
startups happening what countries are
growing in terms of population what what
countries are growing uh in terms of the
ease of creating a business that's what
they're watching when they're looking at
economies and growth
um Matt um yes
was asking if you had an insight into
where India fits into this
Spectrum India um well in it is a a
growing economy
um they are a growing economy but it
like I said there was about 10 to 15
factors of the ability to to build a
business to attract Talent from outside
to uh
taxes uh there was a lot of factors in
there I think India was probably uh in
the top 20
um but it was not in the top five
um I I'd have to go back and see but uh
there was a U.S news and World Report uh
that uh that handled that there okay and
Dinesh had a related question that we
might want to cover in the Q a but uh he
was pointing out the growing economies
10 in this uh chart here are not
English-speaking economy so would
digital marketers be best
advised to focus on local languages
great great question
um I'll tell you what uh I went to the
UAE in uh English
everyone speaks English there are over
160 nationalities represented in the UAE
and if you want to do business you do it
in English
um it was a surprise to me but I do I do
a lot of work with the um the government
there now most of them uh they they
speak Arabic and primarily but they do
know a bit of English and some are very
well versed in English
um so that was a a really kind of a
surprise to me
um and so I think you're seeing that
um a lot of these growing countries uh
you know learn the if you know the local
language that's great
um but what I've seen is there is more
and more English being spoken
um I can't say you know because I speak
English I think that's amazing uh but I
also know that English is one of the
most weird languages in the world uh so
best of luck to you if you were
and we had a a few
audience members who are asking about
Nigeria and so in general were the other
countries in the world where can people
Google the results of the U.S news it's
a great great question
um I will have to I'm trying to look I
left my phone somewhere and it had a
link
um okay but we could we can share that
in the post webinar email yeah yeah I'll
get that to you I think if you want to
Google U.S news and World Report fastest
growing economies uh that should get you
there thank you should get you there
yeah all right
all right okay here's what I'm buying
Creator owned platforms and this is this
is going to shift the industry in the
next five years here's why why am I
selling uh Instagram or not Instagram
why am I selling Twitter why am I
selling Facebook
because five years ago if you wanted to
grow your business everyone told you to
be on Facebook everyone told you to be
on Twitter and so if you put all your
organic social marketing into Facebook
and onto Twitter where are you today
all that content
time money effort creative development
editing it's all gone you put it out
there and and they change their
algorithm so you only get two percent
coverage if you post something on
organic social media only two percent of
your followers will see your content two
percent and so technically you may have
a hundred thousand followers but only
two percent are gonna see your updates
those aren't your followers those
followers belong to Facebook they belong
to Instagram they belong to Twitter
and so what we're seeing more and more
if I'm a Creator and I want to reach
people and I don't want to be dependent
upon some billionaire coming in and
buying a social platform and half the
people leaving
or some billionaire decides to take his
social media company in a different
direction causing people to leave the
platform you see here's the thing all
these social platforms are owned by
billionaires and they can change their
mind do what they want and what happens
to you and the content that you gave
them
seeing here right now is where we're at
with the Creator economy the Creator
economy is I'm creating content and I'm
giving it to a platform
Instagram Facebook Twitter uh YouTube
any of them I'm I'm uploading it and I'm
giving it to them
and then they give me a little bit of
money if I reach a certain amount of
people and show ads
that's it the these platforms don't
create anything they rely on creators to
create the content which brings the
people so they can show the ads so they
can make money and some of that money
trickles down to creators what's
happening right now is creators are
realizing that if that social platform
changes moves this year Instagram went
from an image based platform to a video
based platform and everyone that built
their presence on Instagram on images
was completely lost
because now favorite video and everyone
over the past few years who invested all
of this effort into Instagram was now
lost in now with video
so a platform can change at any time and
what's going to happen to all that you
did so we're seeing more and more
creators moving to platforms where they
are directly supported by their
audiences where they are able to create
without limit great example of this is
nebula
nebula and if you follow any YouTube
creators
I've seen a lot more YouTube creators at
the end of their videos pitching nebula
which is a membership uh if I want to
watch videos there I have to pay
but what's happening is they can create
videos there and they won't get hit by
copyright strikes
they have direct support from their
audiences uh they they don't have to
abide by these platform rules and almost
arbitrary decisions and and copyright
strikes on YouTube are huge
they can kill a Creator but on nebula
they can do what they want uh on um
patreon I can create content and people
can pay what they think it's worth or I
can have different tiers and so we're
going to see more and more uh arise in
these Creator owned platforms where it's
either directly uh directly supported by
audiences who love the content uh and as
you can see there's so many different
aspects so many different platforms that
you can work on uh and and people are
finding that they can make just as much
if not more money there than by doing
ads or anything something else on
YouTube or some of the other platforms
so watch what's happening in this area
uh because the the Creator economy it's
growing uh and here's the thing this is
where Bitcoin possibly nfts are going to
find their way in because now a great
example of this uh was the plotiverse
which is like for photographers and they
can upload all of their work they can
create their own
their own channel really on plotiverse
but if I want to buy an image to use as
uh in my marketing if I want to use it
as stock photography I can buy it
through Bitcoin
because if I buy it through the app any
other way Apple Store gets 30 percent
so isn't this amazing uh so now it's
allowing creators to get all of their
money because they're bringing in
digital money in order to bypass the
this the Apple Store the Google Play
store which takes a cut of everything
and so now we're seeing more
community-based uh tokens uh finance
things like that and so
also what's happening is we're seeing
what we call the direct monetization and
that's where your fans followers your
community
and also Brands can go direct to a
creator
and
indirect monetization is where you're
doing it through ads but it's the direct
monetization is growing as probably one
of the most significant changes in the
industry
now I'm gonna you know very quickly here
I'm going to give you a little bit of an
ad uh when it comes to careers uh I'm
gonna put this in the chat here I think
I've got the um yes uh I just completed
a podcast series called seven digital
marketing skills that I'll never go out
of style I just completed it all seven
are up there it's actually eights I did
an intro uh but I put the link in the
chat window so if you want to hear that
now that'll take you to my site but you
can also I you know please subscribe to
the endless coffee cup if you listen to
podcasts uh and that you'll get this
also very soon my chat with an AI expert
we talk a lot about chat GPT that will
be published in the next few weeks here
uh but if you subscribe you'll get it
all but that'll take you right to the
show page where you can start listening
and get a handle on these but I'm gonna
tell you what they are uh so if you look
at seven skills that are never go out of
style here's what I'm buying all right
number one I'm buying digital and media
literacy all right and why that I mean
this comes down to understanding how the
media Works how the digital ecosystem
works and also digital security all
right media and digital literacy knowing
how these tools work what what drives
things not just you know not just riding
the wave of digital
but understanding what goes on behind
the scenes to make it work
so like I said if you're following the
EU and what the EU is doing you're
getting into how the tool Works don't
just use the tools don't just use the
social media platform
get deep and find out why it works
what's happening what drives get into
the psychology of it and build your
literacy in these areas number two
writing writing skills this goes back
content marketing it's growing it will
continue to grow it will continue to
dominate as a digital strategy what is
content marketing need it needs good
writers copywriters who are skilled at
implementing storytelling around Brands
around products and that can write
compelling content that will draw and
attract users number three Analytics
analytics is probably the top skill in
demand around the world when it comes to
anything digital and it doesn't have to
be Advanced analytics it can simply be
understanding how to take basic data and
make a decision from it website
analytics
um and and building from there that that
will never go out of style at all user
experience
understanding how to build interfaces
that can increase the effectiveness of
what you're doing I've worked with so
many companies where they're frustrated
because they're not making enough sales
they're not getting enough leads and all
we did was fix the interface we made a
better user experience and immediately
sales doubled leads doubled
profitability increased had nothing to
do with the marketing it had everything
to do with the experience
and not even the beginning this goes
into customer experience this goes into
building loyalty this goes into building
long-term audiences it all comes down to
what was the user experience both
through the interface and the
relationship that is huge business
Acumen you may understand SEO you may
know paid search you may know social
media marketing but do you know how they
understand how they impact the
organization
do you understand the difference between
revenue and profit do you know how what
you're doing in digital marketing
impacts the company's bottom line and
can you prove it
that's business Acumen understanding
what the organizational goals are
and how they connect to what you're
doing tactically
that's critical and that requires
analytics six is asking questions the
ability to ask good questions and seven
is presentation skills this is key
presentation skills the omcp all right
the online marketing certified
professional if you are going to get
certified I would look heavily at the
omcp as the primary certification
organization and right now I know we've
got a third of people our University and
college students right now many
recruiters
value digital marketing certification
more than they value a degree
I know that is so hard to hear and
that's because a lot of universities are
not teaching
the correct best practices they're not
up to date in fact in most of my
training the one thing I hear from
college and university students is why
didn't they tell us this why didn't they
show us this
unfortunately undergraduate
training is lacking right now and this
is why recruiters are looking at
certification as as a replacement for a
degree when it comes to candidates why
because certification shows that you are
competent
you have demonstrated experience in
these areas that's why they're looking
for it now in this role delineation
study they found digital marketing as a
career
25
of a digital marketer's time is spent
presenting communicating strategy
practice and results
one-fourth of your time in digital
marketing is presenting and so if you
have presentation skills guess what
you're going to get noticed
it will it and by the way presentation
of anything that you do
any skill that you have you are judged
on presentation skills
because perhaps no other skill reflects
your competence
it is on display when you present and so
that is a huge part of what you are able
to do uh and so this part you know
twenty percent of your time uh is
typically traditional marketing
activities this is all the the Strategic
the Tactical of audience targeting
Persona development market research 15
on content development and copywriting
look at I love this because it backs up
everything that I've seen and
experienced by the way 10 or less on
tactics
that means 10 or less of a digital
marketer's time is spent on the SEO
the paid search 10 or less most of it is
communicating to others and working
within a team and doing the work around
that that's incredible so those of you
looking at this as a career this is
something you really need to be aware of
and how you will develop and where you
will focus your attention all right Matt
uh yes just before we move on yes
a related question France question is
what if you only have practical
experience in digital marketing
what should you do with relation to
certifications
um I would look at the certifications
that may have a practice exam
um and see where you stand on the
practice exam uh you may even if you've
got practical experience
uh some of them you you can take the
certification test uh with if you've got
a I know the omcp if you sub if you
um show how much experience you have
then you're able to sit for an exam I
believe for the the
associate level I think if you have
three years of experience then you can
sit for the exam so look at the
different certifications and see what
they require if you have practical
experience that's fantastic
um you may want to do a little bit of
brushing up to see uh what kind of
skills and competencies they they may
have especially you know in terms of
Industry accepted practices that's what
they're going to be focused on so you
want to make sure your experience lines
up with what they will teach and
determine to be industry standard
yeah
all right all right okay now I'm gonna
give you the the okay the old man Guru
talk all right I've been in this
business now I and I I guess it's like
25 years I've been doing this I have
watched Trends come and go I've seen
things I you know I I've seen you know
the rise of different media different
platforms here's looking back and then
looking forward to my next 25 years in
this industry okay here's here's my Guru
talk to all of you and I'm excited that
so many of you are in college and
university because here's your my career
advice to you number one
don't buy hype all right every year
there's gonna be hype you know we've
seen the hype around chat GPT guess what
this is on a cycle because a couple
months from now something else will hit
the height meter it was metaverse it was
uh you know I'm trying to think what
else it's chat gbt it's there's a media
cycle of hype because whatever's new
whatever is exciting the media is going
to talk about it why because the more
they talk about it the more people click
the Articles the more money they make
the hype cycle is a money making cycle
for media that's what it is so if you
want to learn something
go read the article don't read headlines
go headlines or the most distracting
untrue things that you could read read
the article and when you're reading the
article and this is part of digital
literacy part of digital literacy for
example I saw a statistic the other day
I had to laugh because I think it was
like 80 percent of social media users
have bought something from social media
media
what
and and here's how I could spot that
because I read data I read studies I
look at what's going on but here was the
problem number one it was a crazy click
bait headline
number two when I went and checked and
and number two it was a ridiculous
statistic how did I know it was a
ridiculous statistic because I've
watched the industry I know it and when
I went and double checked the sources
guess what it was a company that
specialized in social commerce that did
the study that created the ridiculous
statistic that was quoted by somebody
else
don't buy hype dig in educate yourself
about how to filter out click bait how
to filter out anything that is
self-serving because what's happening is
companies that are self-interested are
producing studies with crazy statistics
and they're getting picked up by media
they're getting picked up by articles
they're getting picked up by blogs so
don't buy hype
all right number two
invest in yourself
you'll never go wrong by that I mean
certification it's always a great great
option I saw one on here what
organization provides the most valuable
digital marketing certificate uh I will
say there are a couple out there that I
think are better than others uh I I
typically default to the omcp you can
find it at uh o m c p dot org
you can get more information about that
um they're they're probably one of the
best when it comes to uh an industry
board that sets the competencies uh
they're they're the ones that I align
with and have worked with the most
invest in yourself get the skills that
are necessary learn uh what other people
are doing don't just sit in a
specialized area I spoke at a conference
and it was all uh I had a lot of social
media managers
and they were frustrated because they
couldn't justify their position and the
problem was they weren't going to go
into management because all they knew
was social media they didn't know search
they didn't know analytics they didn't
know anything beyond social media and so
because of that you're not going to get
considered for a management position if
you don't know how everything else works
invest in yourself in your education
because this is an industry that is
continually changing number three
create your own many of you are saying
hey I'm still in College University how
do I get experience
create something start now don't wait
build your own website start your own
business start developing income streams
uh by creating content uh by selling it
develop a community create your own
right now one of the best pieces of
advice and I I love this because it was
a former student
she was interested in consumer packaging
and I told her and this was years ago I
told her start a blog start a website
analyzing consumer packaging I said with
every article get a picture of the
package and analyze was it good why is
it bad what are the brand elements and
she started doing that
five years later she's sitting for an
interview at a consumer Brand Packaging
company
and they're looking at a resume and they
asked her what else you know do you have
and she gave them she told them go to
Google and search for Consumer packaging
analysis or something like that her
website outranked the company that she
was interviewing for
she was hired on the spot she's now uh I
think uh she's in the c-suite I think
she is a CMO uh of a consumer packaging
company immediately because she created
something on her own she demonstrated
she knew and understood the industry
better than the company that she was
interviewing for so create something now
create your own why create your own
because if a digital social platform
gets bought by a billionaire and they
change everything
you still have your own stuff you're not
dependent on them
when you let it's your own your fans
your followers your community your
website your content when it's created
on your own you are not subject to the
changes and whims of third-party social
platforms
all right number four
sustainability is better than amazing
growth why because amazing growth can
happen very quickly and it also leave
very quickly focus on sustainability
it was interesting so my my talk with
the AI expert and he was saying what
makes AI work I was laughing about it
because it's the same thing that makes
automation work it's the same thing that
makes using emerging technology work
it's the same thing that Marketing in
order for AI to be effective in a
company it all requires business
Frameworks
defined processes and rules
AI doesn't do it for you you need to
have these things to start and so in
creating your own thing or even working
with an organization
sustainability will this business be
here five years ten years from now
because what will make it be there is
Frameworks processes and rules
establishing things for growth and
focusing on sustainability making sure
that these processes can be repeated if
someone else is in the position
go for sustainability not crazy growth
finally number five
everything is always about the user
experience
everything
this is why I focused on it earlier from
the initial sign up from the landing
page to the process to the sale to the
follow-up to the overall experience of
being a customer it's always always
about the user experience
many of you you may do tech support for
your parents or for your grandparents
that's user experience helping people
navigate a form online helping them
navigate an app helping them figure out
what what I'm supposed to do here
because it's confusing that's user
experience when people have a bad user
experience they have a bad impression of
a brand when they have a great user
experience that's what keeps them there
so that is uh my talk and I think we've
got quite time for questions Stuart if
you're willing to stay a few minutes
past I always do this uh I'm willing to
ask questions and and stay a few minutes
absolutely if you're willing thank you
uh Matt this is this is great um
there's so many questions coming in at
um
a question from Aubry who says that
she's been using uh their
company's been using paid social and
search to get visibility not getting the
results they want
and they're finally realizing the
content marketing
and targeting users organically by
helping them solve a problem or
answering questions is the way to go but
how do you create a Content strategy
to accomplish that wow did we did we do
a webinar on this I'm trying to think
because if not we that should be the
next webinar
Aubry I'll tell you what where I start
is keyword research I go to keyword
research tools and I go find what are
people searching for in your industry
what questions do they have what words
do they use and then I break down those
keywords into where is that in the
buying cycle are they searching for a
solution
and what words how does that work what
are the trends oh you know what
questions they have are they already in
the solution but trying to figure out
how to make it work better how to
optimize how to get more out of it or
are they looking for ways to improve
what they have
so I kind of build some columns as far
as how how the industry searches about
it
and that gives you right there your
content and so keyword research is
probably the number one place I start in
a Content marketing plan
okay uh Richard
asks
uh
planning to move to the UK next year or
so
do you have insights in what the UK or
other countries are better or worse in
terms of jobs for digital marketers wow
Freelancers I do not know
um that I don't know
um I do know from uh right now a lot of
countries are offering what they call a
digital Nomad Visa what that means is if
you're a freelancer Content producer and
you're making a certain level of income
uh you are you can apply for a Visa to
that country uh Portugal uh has it um
the UAE has it
um I'm trying to think some very
attractive destinations have offered
these visas uh to people that are that
are considered a digital Nomad that you
can work from anywhere
um and so I I don't know what the UK is
doing I'm not really sure about the tech
scene there
um it just really depends on what you're
able to find and where you want to focus
your attention uh but if you can I would
look into do a search on some of these
countries that offer the digital Nomad
visas uh you may you may find somewhere
warmer to go
okay
um spoken like someone who lives in the
North Eastern part of the United States
yes but I go to the I go to UAE every
couple months so excellent
um
you had just talked about the user
experience and Leslie asked if ux design
is going to lose relevancy in the future
absolutely not
absolutely not it's going to become more
and more important uh as uh you know
we're going to this app based a lot of
companies are focused on apps in terms
of development and of their audiences of
interactions uh if anything ux ux UI is
going to be in bigger demand uh over the
next few years uh like I said it anyone
who does tech support for their parents
or grandparents helping them navigate
that like health insurance or a Health
Portal it's it's confusing and it
doesn't have to be uh and that comes
down to the usability and accessibility
and those are two areas uh companies may
not realize it but a good uh ux review
can yield immediate immediate results in
Revenue
that that makes perfect sense because
we've all had terrible frustrations uh
when we use certain apps or websites and
and think to ourselves why do they do it
this way
um so
we have a couple of questions about
platforms and then I'm going to ask a
couple questions from people asking
about the careers
um one question uh manaf asks say
something about Facebook marketing but
you did would
to reiterate
Facebook marketing is one of the the
things that you would de-emphasize
well you you have it
s sizing Instagram I'm de-emphasizing
Facebook
um now that still depends on where your
audience is uh this is this is still I'm
just saying in general when I give these
things but if you are focusing on for
example I know some I know a company
right now they are focused on people
55 and older on Facebook who have
grandchildren and they show ads because
that's who's on Facebook in the US are
older adults typically with
grandchildren and they're making a
killing because they're not competing
with anybody else they're focused on
older people who have to buy gifts for
grandchildren and they're doing great so
where's your audience
what's unique to them what would make
them be open to seeing your ads on that
platform at that time uh so even though
I gave some very broad generalized
statements it still has its application
into your organization and what you're
trying to do
okay
and uh you touched on it but Richard
asks also
has the organic activity of Instagram
stopped working like it used to since
it seems that um
people are buying followers and likes
and Views and it's
because
yeah
organic reach is is like I said on
Instagram especially organic reach
uh is is two percent or less two
percent's about the average
um you're not and you can post all day
and that's one of the things about
Instagram I find interesting is there's
so many people using it and once you
post the most traffic that you'll ever
get on that post is within the first 24
hours
but yet if I post that same video to
YouTube
and I grow my YouTube audience
um traffic accumulates and it never
stops and so it's I'm always wondering
why people use Instagram uh so uh it's
it's really interesting but all of these
so all of the platforms limit your
organic reach uh so that's
that's one of the things why I say
building your own but then I'm going to
use that social platform to build my
audience I'm gonna I'm going to point
them to a destination that's mine so
that they become my first party
one-on-one direct audience not an
audience that belongs to LinkedIn
Facebook Instagram YouTube they become
my audience and then I build my business
there you go
um Assan says I'm currently studying
development
working as in digital marketing it's not
studying software development I should
say working as a digital marketing uh
professional with about a year and a
half of experience in marketing but also
wants to be a graphic designer
um
so
can you talk about how those three
Fields might be connected are they
absolutely yeah I mean that's kind of
what we talked about with the user
interface
um it you need to have a good grasp of
design I'll give you a great example
that every time I go speak at a
conference they give me their slide
decks and those slide decks are always
terrible you know because they were
designed by a designer who's never given
a presentation they don't understand how
an audience will see the slide and and
the busier the slide is the less
effective it is
um so understanding how design and and
so I would look at anything that has to
do with neuromarketing anything that has
to do with effective design for a
digital presentation websites apps
anything like that where an eye tracking
studies
you can integrate programming design and
and re if the more you understand
interface the better and really I think
the more valuable your skills will be
I hosted you for a webinar sometime back
on storytelling and covered a lot of
that material as well so I advise people
take a look through our our YouTube
channel for that
um
and there are some career questions
bavic asked if a person from a Finance
and Accounting background
can learn digital marketing
anyone can learn digital marketing
absolutely it all starts with it and
it's business marketing uh it just
happens to be through these channels
um great example you know I I'm still
gonna Market I'm still going to tell
people that I'm here I want to make
myself findable and so just learning
some basic tactics of how to position
your business how to get it number one
thing I tell people get into Google my
business
start there make sure your your business
listing in Google is correct it's up to
date and you're constantly updating it
and you're putting information there
that's going to increase your visibility
and then you kind of grow to the next
stage which is what's my website look
like what am I asking people to do are
people finding me so it just it's a
natural growth uh start with with one
area and then just start adapting other
areas as you get into well I need to get
more visitors okay what's the best way
to do that what's the most economical
way to do that and that carries along
with it a certain set of tactics in
order to make that happen
uh opal asks learning digital marketing
for a month and they're looking for
real-time projects to do where can
I will find Opportunities to do those
types of things that will get hands-on
experience
great great question I would start like
I said this this goes back to my advice
of build your own all right
um
a lot of and that's the thing I I know a
lot of companies are approached by
people that want to see their analytics
or see or evaluate their site and not a
lot of companies are going to be open to
that
um unfortunately that's just people
aren't really comfortable with that kind
of approach unless you have a personal
unless you know somebody personally
um and and ask a favor uh it's it won't
work so number one if you you can find
someone that you know really well that
you say I want to help you I want to do
this and and see where it goes from
there number two build your own go to
wordpress.org and start your website
just uh now you can go for the hosted
version or if you you have some money
and it doesn't take a lot to get a
hosted version of Wordpress where you
control everything and just start
learning how it works
okay
um we have people who have completed
courses some
mohanna completed the course from Simply
learn uh in digital marketing other
people who are
graduating or completing other courses
so they're asking about how to get their
career started where where can they look
to find jobs as a fresher if they don't
have
um work experience
well that's why that's why I tell people
start your own start your own website
start start becoming a Content producer
in something that you enjoy when I had
my agency when I hired someone new the
first thing they had to do was build a
website usually they'd use WordPress uh
after they got that done and it had to
be done within two weeks uh then my my
next
instruction was to go make money with
this website
and part of that was going to how do you
make money online
there are thousands of ways to make
money online
go figure out what they are go make a
list of them and then see what works for
what you want to do
start building something on your own
don't wait for a job don't wait for uh
don't wait for it start build it and and
the thing is I have people that because
of that
these their websites right now are a
second income and because of that it's
enabled them to buy the car that they
wanted it's enabled them to put you know
to get you know a larger house it's
enabled because they're still making
money off of something that they built
15 years ago and it just keeps getting
better and better and and it's just it's
absolutely amazing when you build your
own
it's always with you uh so just start
there
um we have a couple of questions from
people who are interested in digital
marketing as a business starting their
own uh agency or consultancy
um what kind of advice can you give to
them and what kinds of services are
valuable to offer in the marketplace
great question I'm gonna back up a
little from that question I'm gonna say
if you are just getting into the
industry you've got a choice do I go
agency or do I go brand all right
there's a there's a couple of pros and
cons to both all right so if you're just
getting into the into it if you go brand
side chances are you're going to be
responsible for one thing all right uh
and it may be like paid search on Google
um and and that's what you're
responsible for or you're responsible
for dealing with the agency that does it
and working with them so a brand you're
going to get brand experience which is
great being in that atmosphere seeing
how things maybe work together you're
gonna see how silos work and you know
good or bad you're going to get the
brand experience but it's going to be
very limited as to what you're able to
do depending upon the size
if you go to the agency world and this
is what I loved about the agency world
you have a hundred clients
everything from B to B to Brand to small
medium-sized businesses uh lead
generation e-commerce so you're going to
get a lot a business experience and
different business models
um now you may only do one thing but
you're going to learn how it applies in
so many different areas and it's easier
to cross train in an agency because you
know as people come and go and you can
pick up different things so both brand
and agency offer some attractive things
saying you worked for a brand always
gets people's attention when you're in
the job interview however when you've
worked for the agency you've actually
gotten more experience across a wider
variety of businesses so that's the
thing and so before and and so those of
you that want to start your own agency I
would challenge you to work for an
agency for at least a year
maybe two years before you start your
own
why learn how they do it
learn not just how they work with
clients but learn how the agency works
learn how to mark up your services how
to price things how to make proposals
how to work with clients learn the
structure of how an agency works for a
year or two before you start your own
okay it will be invaluable you may hate
it you may love it but get an
understanding of how it works before you
start your own thing okay
we have a couple related questions from
adarsh and Elena who asked a darches
question is can you continue to work in
technical aspects instead of learning
towards the manager's role you have that
kind of hierarchy in digital marketing
and related to that Elena asks where
does digital marketing end and where
does programming and web development and
coding start
where do you draw the line between
digital marketing versus technical
great great questions
um
people ask me if knowing HTML is
critical to SEO
and I tell them
no
but it will help Advance your career it
will help when you can identify the
problems okay so if you're an SEO but
you don't know the technical side you're
limited you can't troubleshoot if
there's something wrong now it also
depends on the organization that you're
in if I'm in a large company and I'm a
I'm a digital marketer I never touch the
programming I never touched the
technical
I can be and that's because in a large
company you'll find content writers
you'll find marketers and and people
that are in charge of campaigns but they
never touch the technical because that
is I.T or that's whoever manages the
website the technical side is typically
very removed and I've worked with a lot
of seos and large brands
they never deal with technical it's it's
some reason been very divorced uh
smaller companies like a mid-sized
company where if you're in marketing you
do everything so there it's going to be
very valuable to have that technical
skill along with the marketing skill
um in an eight in an agency that can
really help build your uh value within
the agency when you can bring those two
together but typically in a large
company and a large brand they're going
to separate those things so it just
depends on and and this is all
generalities just depends on where your
career path takes you of whether that
will be a valuable skill set or it may
be separated and you have nothing to do
with it I know a lot of seos who worked
for large Brands who were so very
frustrated because they knew the
problems because they knew the
programming but it was completely out of
their hands it was in someone else's
hands and we can't take that code that's
Legacy code and it was so frustrating to
those that could solve the problem they
knew what the problem was but they were
not allowed to touch it so I hope that
helps I hate that
um yes we have a couple of questions
from content writers when this uh
speaker and one is AJ and um
so they're
speakers question in Aegis is related is
where could completing a digital
marketing certification
take their careers
um develop in content marketing
we're the best paths to grow their
careers wow
um I'll tell you right now there if you
can write well uh there is so much
Demand right now
um for Content producers content writers
uh the omcp that I I cited a couple of
times uh in their research they found
that people with that certification earn
between 16 and 25 percent more
than non-certified marketers
um that that says a lot because it it it
demonstrates that you've got the
knowledge
um now there are some technical aspects
to that certification
um but a lot of them have to do with
understanding that larger picture of
marketing and that's what the
certification does is if you can write
content but you understand the larger
picture how will this content achieve
organizational objectives that's where
certification helps you see more of that
bigger picture and so when you go into
an interview you're not just being
you're not just focusing on oh they want
me to do this little bit of content or
this little bit of responsibility you
can speak to the organization you can
speak to a wider picture which shows
your your vision it shows your
capabilities of
being more valuable to the organization
than just a role player
I've got a few more questions one is
from shifa who's a digital marketing
intern who would like to know more about
the importance of backlinks and blogs
yeah backlinks uh now Google said
they're devaluing backlinks which I was
like okay uh it's still important and
but I'll tell you what uh and I'm gonna
cut through since we're like on time we
could do a whole presentation on
backlinks
I love PR
optimizing press releases is probably
one of the best ways right now to get
backlinks because it's getting picked up
by media it's getting picked up by blogs
getting picked up and people are linking
back to you I love online PR as a way of
building backlinks number two studies
research uh I just did an audit for a
company and 70 of their backlinks came
from one research document that they
published and it was all done within a
year
within the past year they published
research 70 of the backlinks came from
that research document
um that produces and then number two
podcasting
um since I've been podcasting the amount
of backlinks I get is just insane
especially when I'm a guest on other
shows or anything like that
um there's a podcasting has created an
incredible network of links so those are
three areas where I have seen backlinks
just go crazy uh and and really benefit
uh the activities in there
excellent
um if you have a couple more minutes do
you yeah okay
um
need to ask about the Creator owned
platforms do they work well with web3
well that those are web free properties
they're web 3 definitions which is uh an
interactive method to build a community
and part of that is the the monetization
of that Community either direct through
um direct through digital currency or
indirect through payment methods so
those communities are they fit the
definition of web three absolutely
um because that's a Creator driven
platform that enables payment uh and so
payment and Community buildings so
absolutely they are
uh drawing on your experience from
starting 25 years ago uh so Nevada asks
he's from Cameron where digital
marketing is not really well known
um how does how does he become a Pioneer
in bringing that
Market
um so working in some developing
countries
um for example I I work in a couple
countries where Instagram is the
internet
um when I talk about anything Instagram
is the first thing that people think of
and mainly because when the internet was
introduced to that country on a mass
scale
mobile phones and Instagram were the big
news
so people didn't have it prior to that
there were very few had it when it was a
PC on a desk
so the internet to them meant that it
was always on the phone and it was an
app and so they think Instagram first
my question to them is what do you do
when you have a question where do you go
Google
everybody goes to Google when they have
a question and and so what I'm trying to
teach them in these emerging economies
and countries is yes you may use
Instagram
you know four hours a day
but everybody goes to Google when they
have a question what if your business
was in the Google results in the top
three
now they're starting to think that's the
thing is is at and this gets back to my
my skill asking questions you can't tell
people what they need to do
if you ask them questions and enable
them to come to the conclusion that's
what's going to sell your service so
there are ways if you go to I think it
is uh
myactivity.google.com ask someone to do
that and you'll show and it will show
how many Google searches they make in a
day
and ask them to add up how many Google
searches did you do last week and you
can see that on myactivity.google.com
when you have an account
and so if I'm talking to a business
owner who themselves has done over 100
searches in a week like
why wouldn't you want your business to
be found there don't you think everybody
else is doing that kind of search and
then you can do the keyword research to
see what people are searching for in
that area in that country
look for where the demand is and then
that's how you can ask really good
questions to help people come to the
conclusion themselves
all right I'm down to the last two
questions we have time for one is uh
Vijay uh says that they really love the
analysis you've done how can
they track the same kinds of Trends and
topics on their own
uh boy like I said keyword research a
lot of your keyword research tools will
show you Trends uh throughout the past
12 months I also used uh Trends I'm
going to put it into the chat here
trans.google.com
um now trends.google.com you can select
your country you can select uh and and
usually what I will do is I will look at
the past five years
so I will put a keyword in and I will
look to see and Google Trends will show
you the demand of that keyword or of the
topic over the past year and then I
expand that to five years and from there
I can see if there is an annual Trend
why is it there what surrounds that what
are people looking for and then that
helps me figure out what kind of Trends
there are
excellent and then the last question I
had time for is
thumbia asks if you could compare you
know the prospects for data scientists
versus digital marketer do you think
that the those two things are comparable
in any way or related in some way so a
data scientist so when I talked about
analytics there's different levels of
analytics there's the the website
analytics and that's getting into what's
working why it's working answering you
know what channels are most effective
and do my processes work am I getting
people through so that's that's
answering questions about that data
science is much bigger and it goes into
a more organizational of looking for
what are the patterns that we're seeing
uh what you're doing is is essentially
it's you know more accounting of trying
to find what are the relationships how
do we maximize profitability uh what are
key factors and so you're going to be
doing more work with AI uh in finding
those factors but it always comes down
to a human then to figure out what's
that causality what is it that caused
that to happen and if we fix this how
would we modify it what would we do so
that's where data science it's that next
level Beyond analytics of really it's
more like a digital accountant uh of
data and those are that that's just
going to increase because the the more
AI takes over the more we're going to
need humans
to tell us what's going on with the AI
so absolutely
okay I apologize to everyone whose
questions we couldn't take
Matt's been more than generous at this
time so I'm going to
put back up his his links and also I
dropped yeah she can reach me on you
know what if you have questions uh go to
LinkedIn go to LinkedIn uh connect with
me and put your question and and your
message and uh you know what if I don't
answer it then I'll put it in a podcast
so absolutely yeah I'm dropping into the
chat window right now your uh Matt's URL
so you can put that right there oops
sorry running the wrong way
um but let's close off with uh
question or two and a little bit about
one of our
certification programs and this question
I'll leave it open for about 30 seconds
what are the skills in digital marketing
that you want to add to your personal
toolkit and you can mark off as many as
apply to you and when would you like to
start acquiring those skills
and
so the pull result here
that's a pretty even distribution across
the different skill sets analytics and
uh
CEO content and analytics that's where I
started and I I love that and
most of the audience wants to start
right away so let me share with you
really quickly
last few seconds here
professional certificate program digital
marketing is one of the programs that we
offer this one is in collaboration with
Purdue University it's a six-month
program uh it's all online access from
anywhere in the world this Edition is
meant for Learners outside of the United
States we also have an addition that is
uh boot camp for Learners within the
United States
um but in both cases you're covering a
comprehensive curriculum a number of
Hands-On projects uh the
university-affiliated program lets you
access their Alumni Association get
master classes from their instructors
this one also has master classes from
meta and your additional certifications
from meta blueprint
you get hands-on experience with a wide
range of tools and platforms as part of
the coursework
and so just a quick question
whether this is something you might be
interested in doing
I'll leave that open for a few seconds
here
and
close the poll in about 10 seconds so do
get your answers in
and about 90 percent of the audience is
interested uh somewhat or very in this
program so we will share with you uh
information about how to get involved
with that but I do want to let you know
that you can contact us about our
programs at
um
ask us at simplylearn.net and we'll also
give you the URL here
for this program page which you can also
get by the
QR code
this is
the program page you can reach there and
then also
putting uh the email address into the
chat as well so take a look in the chat
box you can see those things
and with that I want to
I did want to show the poll results I
don't know if I did
then of that I want to thank
oops
thank Matt one more time thank you so
much for being here and and taking so
much time to answer our audience's
questions today Matt really appreciate
that oh of course I I love this career
stuff and I love especially uh working
with students here to figure out how
this crazy industry works so absolutely
thank you very much and and I want to
thank everybody in the audience for
being here today
um we hope that you found this helpful
to you and we'd love to see you at
Future simply learn webinars and we also
love to welcome you into our Learning
Community uh connect with us on Facebook
and Twitter at simplylearn but most
importantly connect with us on LinkedIn
simply learn how you find us and well we
hope to see you again soon so that
concludes our webinar for today thanks
so much
foreign